wildwest in berlin blut poker bube dame
könig tod das sind die schlagzeilen zu
unserem nächsten fall der begann mit
einer roma hochzeit hier in berlin und
endete mit tödlichen kopfschüssen
matthias becker stefan sander und dirk
böttger über eine eiskalte blutrache
mitten in der hauptstadt
es ist der zweite oktober kurz nach 23
uhr als vor der bar in der schulstraße
im berliner wedding schüsse fallen
zeugen alarmierten polizei und
rettungskräfte auf dem gehweg liegt ein
mann in einer riesigen blutlache
es ist hamid am
zweiten oktober erschienen hamid hier
vor der shisha bar hier wurde er
hingerichtet wie im kinofilm
hingerichtet mit zwei kopfschüssen
eiskalt und brutal
und so soll das ganze laut augenzeugen
abgelaufen sein armero entspannt in der
shisha bar als er hamid entdeckt
armero läuft nach draußen holt wohl
seine waffe und schießt seinem opfer in
den hinterkopf
um sicherzugehen dass hertha wirklich
tot ist schießt er ihm noch ein zweites
mal
eine hinrichtung auf offener straße
unfassbar nach bilde herrschen war der
mutmaßliche täter am erst seit wenigen
tagen auf freien fuß der fehde mord
geschah auf hafturlaub
am 27 oktober 2018 herrscht auf einer
großen roma hochzeit wie dieser in
berlin-spandau die freude und das glück
ein 14 jahre dauernder streit zwischen
den familien h und soll durch heirat
beigelegt werden doch der plan läuft
schief die situation eskaliert
betrunken verlässt hamid h die
hochzeitsfeier will im café 63 in
berlin-wedding noch ein pokerspiel
machen vor wenigen stunden
und friede auf der roma hochzeit doch
dann brach die alte familienfehde wieder
auf hier auf dem gehweg wo früher das
café 63 war wurde die schwester vom
eigenen bruder erschossen
und so soll das ganze abgelaufen sein
parameta trifft auf familie odin mit
sechs personen bewaffnet mit beil hammer
und hockeyschläger über 130 mal auf hama
einschlagen als plötzlich die tür des
lokals aufgeht und amina es hereinkommt
fällt ein schuss die junge frau erleidet
einen bauchschuss und verblutet eine
tragödie denn der schütze ist der eigene
bruder der tödliche schuss löste sich
bei der attacke unabsichtlich aus seiner
pistole samir wird wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung und fahrlässiger tötung
im juni 2009 10 zu drei jahren und zehn
monaten haft verurteilt doch die familie
von simyo gibt dem schwer verletzten
hamit die schuld für die tödliche
eskalation
[Musik]
nach der familientragödie legte ein
stammes gericht fest dass sich die
beiden verfeindeten familien nicht nur
unterhalten sollten zudem sollte hamid
deutschland für zwei jahre verlassen
doch hamid kehrt zurück nach berlin geht
am zweiten oktober dieses jahres zur
shisha bar im berliner wedding die
jahrelange familienfehde eskaliert und
hamm etat wird hingerichtet
zwei wochen später lokalisieren
zielfahnder den mutmaßlichen täter
armero in regensburg spezialeinheiten
überwältigen den jungen mann auf offener
straße erwartet dort auf die
überstellung in ein berliner gefängnis
über diese familienfehde wollen wir hier
in unserem studio weiter sprechen mit
matthias becker unserem reporter schön
dass du da bist matthias lasst uns
einmal zurück springt diese fehde dieser
streit zwischen diesen beiden familien
der begann mit einem streit im kino was
ist damals passiert
wirst kam eigentlich erst raus in dem
prozess bei dem es um den tod der
schwester ging das 2004 die beiden
familien zusammen sich in einem kino
trafen und dann hat man sich um einen
sitzplatz gestritten beide reklamierten
den platz für sich und wollten nahe bei
ihrer familie sitzen keiner der
streithähne wollte klein beigeben und
dann eskalierte es mit diesen tragischen
nachhaltigen folgen die folgen also
einmal eine tote frau und dann jetzt
eben der mann der da auf offener straße
hingerichtet wird mit all deiner
erfahrung drohen da noch weitere opfer
in diesem streit
entscheidend bei diesen familiären
geschichten gerade in dem südlichen
gefilden da spielen stammes gerichten
friedensrichter bei den arabern und bei
sinti roma vielen stammes gericht eine
ganz entscheidende rolle da kommt es
darauf an ob dieser laienrichter der
die macht hat zu entscheiden wer zeigt
welche art von blutgeld welche höhe wenn
der es schafft beide familien so zu
trennen und so zu befriedigen dann
herrscht ruhe sollte aber so wie in dem
ersten teil dieses falles
alte fehden wieder aufbrechen plötzlich
dann dann eskaliert es weiterhin und
dann wird blutrache zur blutrache man
muss das vielleicht noch mal ein orden
für leute die ich aus berlin kommen
diese richter das sind also keine
offiziellen richter sondern eben
privatpersonen eigentlich etwas gesagt
arabische clans der laufen die dann
selbst mit schusssicherer weste um bei
dieser beruf auch doch so gefährlich ist
über dieses gericht nun in diesen
zwischen diesen roma verfangen wissen
wir da irgendetwas wissen wir wo dieses
stammes gericht sitzt wieder geurteilt
und entschieden wird also ein fall von
mach modell zahlen habe ich selber
sowohl mit mahmut als hain als auch mit
dem friedensrichter genannte sich damals
alushi mittlerweile ist er auch
verstorben habe ich beide sprechen
können er sagte immer man wie weiße
taube die treffen sich entweder in
shisha bars oder lokalitäten auf jeden
fall neutralem boden selten in der
wohnung des friedens richter da wird
seltener stattfinden da treffen die
aufeinander man schickt abgesandte
teilweise weiß ich auch aus anderen
mordfällen denn dann abhör gespräche
sind trifft man sich auch in
rechtsanwaltskanzleien auf neutralem
boden und dort wird dann richtig
verhandelt was uns fasziniert hat die
taten die waren in berlin aber der
tatverdächtige der ist jetzt in
regensburg geschnappt worden wie passt
das zusammen wenn man muss sehen dass
diese großen familien diese ganzen
verbände das sind ja nicht so kleinst
familien wie wir sie aus deutschland her
traditionell kennen sondern sie sind
großfamilien die namen dieser familien
entstammen auch teilweise dörfern oder
gebieten deswegen sind sie nicht primär
auf verband in erster linie und die sind
schon seit jahrhunderten über westeuropa
verteilt und haben ihre eigene community
jetzt hast du es vorhin selbst
angesprochen hier in berlin da kennt man
die libanesischen klar ins arabische
clans türkische familien bundes wie groß
ist dieses problem von roma clans
hierfür die polizei in berlin dass das
ehren randphänomen
das problem ist für die polizei die
klare stringent
nachweis und beweispflicht zu haben um
zu gucken ist das ein klassischer klar
weil meistens sitzen die wirklichen clan
chefs immer noch in bulgarien oder
rumänien und die sogenannten clouds oder
die battle kinder die wir hier haben und
hier kennen und das problem der polizei
darstellen die sind nur für wenige
wochen in der stadt beziehungsweise
niemand von den ermittlungsbehörden wird
über die wahre existenz den hintermann
dem boss der bosse
was erkennen können man muss das
vielleicht auch noch mal sagen diese
cloud kids sind ja oft selbst opfer in
diesen strukturen und sind eben selbst
wenn am ende dazu gezwungen was sie da
eigentlich tun sollen matthias vielen
vielen dank dass du da warst und dass du
uns diese spannenden recherchen
mitgebracht hat danke